[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue à l'édition
du 7 8 l'hebdo une émission pour revenir
sur l'actualité départementale de la
semaine voici les titres de ce vendredi
12 mai le style de paris saclay et
candidat candidat pour accueillir le
village global de l'exposition
universelle 2025 les élus locaux de tous
bords se mobilisent en ce moment pour le
projet à une semaine du dépôt des
candidatures
aurore bergé notre invité fil rouge pour
cette émission conseillère municipale à
magny les hameaux conseillère
communautaire à saint-quentin désormais
candidate aux élections législatives sur
la 10e circonscription des yvelines sous
l'étiquette la république en marche
nous évoquerons avec notamment le duel
qui va l'opposer au député sortant
jean-frédéric poisson
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité
retour sur les avancées du chantier de
la rd 30 à plaisir ou encore le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
qui a accueilli mercredi une épreuve de
cyclisme sur piste méconnu la coupe de
france de l'américaine mais on ouvre
cette émission sur l'hommage rendu ce
matin aux policiers morts pour la france
est en opération la cérémonie avait lieu
dans la cour d'honneur de la préfecture
des yvelines à versailles en présence
notamment de serge morvan le préfet des
yvelines karl olive le maire de poissy
où pascal thévenot encore le député l
ère de la 2e circonscription des
yvelines durant la cérémonie
soixante cinq policiers ont été décorés
c'est un enjeu majeur plus de 40
millions de personnes devraient s'y
rendre en 2025 si paris accueille
l'exposition universelle le site de
paris saclay est candidat pour
accueillir le village global de
l'exposition l'un des épicentres
essentiel de l'événement l'ensemble des
élus locaux sont mobilisés pour la cause
nicolas d'andry trois photos du projet
paris saclay 2025 d illustration de ce
que serait le village global lors de
l'exposition universelle
l'agglomération s'est lancé depuis trois
ans pour représenter la france et
accueillir l'événement mondial en 2025
un projet soutenu aussi par les
habitants du territoire alors justement
j'ai pris en photo parce que je trouve
que les images sont très belles et donne
très envie d'avoir cette expo
universelle c'est important parce que
man c'est la concrétisation universel du
cluster est en cours sur ce territoire
on a aujourd'hui des infrastructures qui
vont se développer notamment le grand
paris express
on n'allait nulle universités qui sont
déjà présentes on a un cadre
environnemental qui est magnifique avec
la vallée de chevreuse donc je pense
qu'on a les atouts et je pense que ce
serait bien pour l'économie pour le
développement social culturel de la
région
le président du conseil départemental de
l'essonne françois durovray et michel
bournat président de la communauté
d'agglomération paris saclay ont réussi
à fédérer les collectivités locales
autour du projet notamment les communes
dorcé de gif sur yvette et même au delà
du département près de 60 millions de
visiteurs sont attendus sur le village
global
nous avons les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur de recherche
nous avons des sites exceptionnels de
tels que château de versailles
et quand on additionne ces éléments
académiques culturels économiques comme
s'inscrit parfaitement dans les logiques
qui sont mises en avant pour le métro is
universel plusieurs sites sont dans la
course face à paris saclay gonesse
marne-la-vallée ou encore la vallée de
l'ourcq
le dépôt des dossiers est prévue le 19
mai le territoire d'accueil du village
global en france sera connu le 25 juin
prochain pour un choix final entre la
france et le japon en novembre 2018
également dans l'actualité avec les
partis à qui dévoile progressivement
leurs candidats pour les élections
législatives
la bataille s'annonce farouche sur
certaines circonscription des yvelines
c'est notamment le cas sur la 11e celle
du socialiste benoît hamon qui se
reposer comme il ya cinq ans à jean
michel fourgous le candidat ait l'air il
faudra compter aussi sur l'inconnu en
marche nadia et écoutez à ce propos le
maire d'elancourt au micro de mélanie
poker pour le député il faut un peu de
compréhension juridique quand même fait
des lois financières parce qu'il faut
mesurer l'impact de la loi vous avait
proposé il faut en management faut avoir
vu des hommes et des femmes travaillent
et de différentes nationalités
la mondialisation l'européanisation la
décentralisation comprendre tout ça bon
donc il faut un minimum de culte de
culture et c'est vrai que d'avoir été
élu mais même d'avoir été prise une
grosse association c'est pas mal ou
conseiller municipal ou maire ou
conseiller départemental
aurore bergé bonsoir vous en êtes
candidate la république en marche le
mouvement des manuels macron sur la 10e
circonscription des yvelines
une réaction à ce que vous venez
d'entendre de la part de l'un de vos
collègues à l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
n'at-il pas raison finalement quelque
part sur le fait qu'il faut connaître
quelques règles endroit quelques règles
peut-être pour construire un budget
quand on va être potentiellement amenés
à voter un budget pour pour la france
sur les candidats la république en
marche qu'on a investi 92% d'entre eux
sont des nouveaux candidats c'est à dire
qu'on a pas réinvesti des sortants si en
gros ce que nous dit jean michel
fourgous et pour être député il faut
l'avoir été où il faut avoir été élu on
n'arrivera jamais à faire du
renouvellement
il faut du renouvellement et après il
faut pas mélanger les sujets je pense
que justement le professionnalisme c'est
aussi le fait d'avoir un métier d'avoir
exercé dans le privé ou dans la fonction
publique d'avoir acquis des compétences
qu'on peut mettre en oeuvre en étant au
service des autres et en s'engageant en
politique alors vous de l'expérience
vous en avez un petit peu puisque vous
êtes conseillère municipale depuis 2014
conseillère communautaire aussi vous
êtes la plus connue des candidats en
marche sur le département des yvelines
avec didier baichère aussi sur la
première circonscription est ce que ça
veut dire vous allez avoir un rôle
particulier pendant cette campagne des
élections législatives un peu de coach
auprès des des plus novices on travaille
évidemment à tous ensemble mais vous
savez moi j'ai il faut pas regarder avec
avec mépris ou condescendants je dis pas
tous que c'est votre cas mais je ne
ferme pas ce que disait jean michel
fourgous le mouvement qu'on a créés en
un an
la république en marche qui était juste
avant en marche a réussi devenir la
première force politique dans notre pays
donc ça veut dire justement que tous ces
citoyens qui se sont engagés pour
beaucoup d'entre eux pour la première
fois ils savent faire de la politique
parce qu'ils ont réussi
à amnéville le maquereau à la présidence
de la république donc moi je vous invite
surtout à aller découvrir les autres
candidats évidemment moi je travaillerai
avec chacun d'entre eux avec beaucoup de
plaisir on va couvrir largement cette
élection à tv fil 78 et une question
encore sur ce monde politique qu'on sait
très très dur avec des personnes qui
sont là depuis des années et des années
qu'on fait des élections parfois
présidentielle régionales
départementales et j'en passe on sait
que c'est un monde difficile est ce que
vous allez apporter peut-être votre
regard votre expérience donné quelques
conseils tout de même sur sur des choses
à savoir avant de peut-être débattre
avec des candidats qui sont là depuis
longtemps
moi je connais évidemment les différents
candidats qui ont été choisis je suis
évidemment à leur disposition ils seront
aussi formés à ces dark le mouvement
n'en vois pas comme ça au feu des gens
sans leur donner les armes aussi pour
savoir comment on fait pour travailler
avec la presse notamment dans le cadre
d'une campagne pour débattre comme vous
le disiez qu'il vont être formés et puis
voilà un mois 5 j'ai une expérience de
campagne que j'ai gagné d'autres que
j'ai perdu dans tous les cas ça forge sa
forme évidemment je me tiens à leur
disposition et on va se revoir tous
ensemble dès lundi justement pour
affronter aussi de manière collégiale
cette élection alors vous êtes candidate
sur la 10e circonscription des yvelines
vous êtes élu à magny les hameaux sur la
2e circonscription des yvelines parfois
le découpage est un petit peu compliqué
mais bref
pourquoi ne pas être candidat sur la 2e
circonscription des yvelines elle vous
aura pas échappé que je suis cancer
communautaire de saint quentin en
yvelines et que poignet raymond repas
sont au synthé ont attesté
d'agglomération et sont dans cette
circonscription
donc je suis pas totalement inconnu où
il légitime sur cette circonscription
c'est aussi une circonscription j'ai
grandi puisque avec mes parents on était
à méré donc juste à côté de montfort
l'amaury et puis c'est vrai que moi d'un
point de vue personnel
c'était un peu délicat pour moi d'être
candidate sur la deuxième c'est à dire
d'être candidate face à des gens avec
lesquels j'avais travaillé je trouvais
qu'il y avait quelque chose aussi
humainement qui était un petit peu
compliqué pour moi d'être aujourd'hui
face à eux
alors évidemment si j'en avais la rocqué
candidats sur la deuxième et moi
évidemment je le soutiendrai je voterai
pour lui mais si vous voulez je voulais
pas qu'ils aient une confusion qu'ils
puissent se créer par rapport justement
à une histoire qu'on a pu avoir ensemble
et puis le combat sur la dixième il vous
aura pas échappé que c'est jean frédéric
poisson député sortant et qu'on à peu
près dit à m
bien reposés surtout qu'ils étaient
candidats à la primaire de la droite et
du centre à l'époque où vous soutenir
alain juppé vous avez quelque part était
amené aussi à travailler avec lui mais
faire partie du même groupe politique
mais jamais ce qui nous oppose
principales entrées directes façon déjà
il est le président du parti chrétien
démocrate il n'est pas au sens des
républicains donc moi ma famille ça a
été l'ump ça a été les républicains ça
n'a jamais était le parti chrétien
démocrate
et puis on est à peu près je vous disais
diamétralement opposées surtout jean
frédéric poisson il veut revenir sur
lille et g il a voté contre toutes les
lois qui permettent de renforcer les
droits des femmes
moi c'est un combat qui est essentiel
pour moi et qui à la source de mon
engagement politique
il a été de toutes les manifs pour tous
contre le mariage pour tous il vend
aujourd'hui encore abroger la loi
là où dans mon avis ça réouvrirait des
plaies qui sont inutiles
il est allé plusieurs fois en syrie pour
rencontrer bachar el assad
ils préfèrent aller voir poutine et se
rapprocher l'ups renforcer l'union
européenne il veut supprimer le
ministère de la culture on dit qu'on
veut défendre l'identité française c'est
un peu compliqué et d'essayer de
justifier derrière on veut supprimer nsa
la culture je vais vraiment on est à peu
près opposés sur l'ensemble des sujets
que même sur les questions économiques
moi je suis vraiment libéral et lui
l'est beaucoup moins en tout cas ça
serait une campagne on va dire de fond
c'était une critique on a beaucoup fait
pendant cette élection présidentielle ça
manquait un peu de hauteur est ce que
vous souhaitez que cette campagne
prennent un peu plus de hauteur
justement puisqu'on sait que vous êtes
quand même une opposante assez dur ça a
été assez dur la campagne 2014 avec
bertrand lyon le maire ps de
magny-les-hameaux là vous voulez une
campagne sur le fond
vraiment mais moi j'ai fait une campagne
sur le fond aussi en 2014 parce que la
campagne peut être dur parce que
justement on s'oppose sur des projets
mais évidemment moi je veux qu'on
continue à défendre mon problème moi je
suis très curieuse savoir quel est le
projet que jean frédéric poisson à
vouloir défendre
est-ce que c'est celui de françois
fillon candidat l'élection
présidentielle est-ce que c'est celui
des républicains
est-ce que c'est celui du parti chrétien
démocrate j'ai l'impression ya quand
même un peu une confusion des genres
dans l'est dans les différents projets
nous notre force est la cohérence du
projet projet qu'on a présenté le projet
qu'elle menait le maquereau aujourd'hui
président de la république a présenté
aux français c'est le même projet que
l'on va présenter lors de ces élections
législatives et aux très honnêtement
cette campagne elle a manqué de hauteur
s'est aussi beaucoup parce que la
campagne nous a été confisqué par les
affaires des 10
errant candidats savoir marine le pen et
françois filon certainement pas alors un
argument que votre candidat va peut-être
mettre en avant contre vous c'est le
fait d'être passé on va dire plus ou
moins par la case nicolas sarkozy après
la case alain juppé puis maintenant
emmanuel macron est ce que vous êtes
prête à répondre à cet argument et
comment vous allez vous défendre face à
vos potentiels adversaires qui vont
sûrement vous vous je vous annoncer cet
argument comme en saison commençait déjà
menées sur les réseaux sociaux
je les ai vus relayé d'ailleurs des
articles qui viennent de sites
d'information qui sont plutôt liées à la
fachosphère dont je trouve ça
intéressant
ils ont même relayé je vous parlais
aussi devenu pour la campagne sais pas
ce que je fais voyez il ya même un faux
comptes qui s'est créée en marche
rambouillet qui dénonçait mon
investiture en disant qu'elle était très
contesté par les militants manque de pot
c'est un faux compte mais que l'équipe
de campagne de jean frédéric poisson à
relier tout au long de la journée
donc il a fallu que tous nos soutiens
les adhérents de rambouillet de non mais
attendez
nous on est ravi de cette investiture et
on a envie de faire campagne avec elle
donc moi je veux qu'on parle du fond et
le fond c'est justement aussi les
projets de lois contre lesquels jean
frédéric poisson a voté les amendements
qu'il a déposée à l'assemblée nationale
sur les différents sujets qu'on a évoqué
et puis moi je me tiens prête évidemment
à tous les débats que nous pourrons
organiser l'un face à l'autre et avec
aussi les autres candidats alors on va
voir à l'écran de s'afficher le score
des candidats au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle à rambouillet
la ville principale de la
circonscription françois fillon est
arrivé premier ce qui prouve que la
droite résiste dans le sud du
département
comment vous comptez ramené à vous
certains électeurs de françois fillon
qui vont probablement voter jean
frédéric poisson puis aussi ceux de jean
luc mélenchon marie le pen
qu'est ce que vous allez mettre en place
pour tenter de les attirer là vous avez
sur l'ensemble de la circonscription et
le maquereau est arrivé en tête
il est arrivé à 29% françois fillon à 28
heures c'est serré et c'est quand même
aussi un signal que sur cette
circonscription que l'on dit imprenable
eh bien elle macro ont été placés en
tête dès le premier tour
et puis ce qui est aussi intéressant
c'est le second tour puisqu'il fait plus
de 77% sur la circonscription
malgré la consigne de vote de jean
frédéric poisson qui était de dire il ne
faut pas voter mal macron face à
l'extrême droite face à marine
donc moi je pense que c'est extrêmement
ouvert et donc je vais aller les voir je
vais pour aller sur le terrain faire du
porte-à-porte les rencontrer dialoguer
et défendent le projet qui le projet
qu'on a défendu dans le cas de la
présidentielle et qui lui contrairement
aux projets des autres candidats n'a pas
varié pour les législatives alors
précision pour ceux qui nous regardent
en 2012 jean frédéric poisson avait
remporté l'élection au second tour face
à face à une candidate écologiste avec
53 20 65 % des voix si on ne veut que
des propositions concrètes maintenant la
10e circonscription c'est assez rural tu
m'aimes est ce que vous avez un thème de
campagne vous allez porter
principalement pour la pour la ruralité
ou autre sur la ruralité on a des
propositions très claires
par exemple le fait qu'on ne souhaite
plus qu'il ait des fermetures de classes
la ruralité elle a beaucoup souffert de
la perte de services publics de
proximité l'école c'est probablement le
service public est le plus important
évidemment dans la transmission des
savoirs et aussi dans la vie locale que
ça peut générer
or on le sait quand il ya des fermetures
une fermeture de classe a fait entrer
les fermetures d'écoles dans la ruralité
neil mc ren a pris un engagement très
ferme il n'y aura plus aucune fermeture
de classe dans les zones rurales
il ya aussi toute la question de la
fracture numérique on donne 18 mois à
partir du moment où on sera en
responsabilité aux opérateurs pour
équiper en fibre
sinon l'état prendra ses responsabilités
là où les opérateurs seront défaillant
donc à ces sujets et puis enfin il ya la
question écologique et de l'agriculture
on a un plan d'investissement de 50
milliards 15 milliards sont fléchés sur
la transition écologique et énergétique
5 milliards pour les agriculteurs aurore
bergé
restez avec nous on passe tout de suite
à l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
une actualité marquée évidemment par de
la politique et lundi la rédaction de tv
fils vous propose une émission spéciale
dédiée aux résultats dans le département
de l'élection présidentielle on revoit
le score de ce second tour avec une
victoire nette dans les yvelines d'
emmanuel macron 77 15 % des suffrages
exprimés ces dix points c'est plus de 10
points au dessus de la moyenne nationale
et malgré ce plébiscite la semaine n'a
pas été de tout repos avec une première
brouille hier avec le modem le parti de
françois bayrou
c'était jeudi soir le président du parti
centriste n'a pas donné son aval aux 428
investiture présenter il évoque dans la
presse une opération de recyclage du ps
je me tourne vers vous aurez un berger
c'est clairement le premier couac du
mandat d' emmanuel macron a coûté en
tout cas moi je suis pas issu du
recyclage du parti socialiste
donc voilà ça montre aussi que diverses
dans les candidats on a réinvesti que 24
députés sortants qui viennent en effet
de la gauche et des écologistes
tout simplement parce que c'est les
parlementaires qui avaient
courageusement décidé de quitter le
parti social de justement pour jours des
mails macron et 24 députés sortants
regardez combien le parent cialis tous
les républicains eux leur politique
c'est de réinvestir systématiquement les
sortants nous on à 92% de renouvellement
en tout cas c'est par cette crise on va
dire avec françois bayrou c'est une
crise de passage ce n'est rien de
sérieux selon vous on sait que
l'actualité bouge très rapidement en ce
moment ça va continuer avec la
nomination du premier ministre en début
de semaine prochaine vous pensez que
c'est une crise de passage clairement
moi je suis pas inquiète et c'est ce qui
est important aussi c'est le projet le
premier projet de loi que le président
de la république ionel mâcon souhaite
présenter sur la moralisation de la vie
publique l'éthique en politique
la limitation du cumul des mandats dans
le temps le fait qu'on a plus de double
cotisation à la retraite quand on est
parlementaire
tout ça ça fait partie justement de
l'alliance qui s'est nouée avec françois
bayrou et je pense qu'au delà des
candidatures et des investitures
il ya aussi le projet qu'on va mettre en
oeuvre est clairement le modem et
françois bayrou auront contribué à ce
programme alors l'autre problématique
pour emmanuel macron et qui devrait se
décanter en début de semaine prochaine
c'est l'ouverture à droite vous en venez
vous
de la droite des républicains on peut
dire clairement aujourd'hui vous êtes un
peu la tête d'affiche de la droite dans
le mouvement en marche
vous qui avez sûrement encore des
contacts à droite est ce que vous savez
qui s'ils sont nombreux à vouloir vous
suivre encore s'il ya des députés des
anciens ministres qui vont suivre votre
votre démarche avoue rien à un certain
nombre déjà france jean jacques aillagon
et renaud jean marie savait comment
marie idrac
on pense à bruno le maire va vous parler
dans un ministre c'est pas les moindres
des anciens ministres qui ont rejoints
et des parlementaires jean mathis
lemoine qu'un jeune parlementaire qui
avait aussi également rejoint moi je
pense que dans les jours qui viennent
en effet il y aura une dynamique qui va
s'amplifier en faveur de cette
recomposition qu'on est en train de
vivre les vieux partis sont en train de
mourir tout simplement et je pense que
c'est sain parce qu'ils n'avaient plus
grand chose en commun et on l'a bien vu
dans le cadre de leur primaire où il
défend des des projets qui étaient
extrêmement différents il aurait fallu
au lendemain la primaire en face comme
si tous ces débats n'avaient pas eu lieu
et hop on les oublie et on salit parce
qu'on est dans une caserne moi c'était
ma vision de la politique je crois que
c'est pas là disons que les français ont
envie de la politique est-ce que vous
avez des informations sur le choix du
premier ministre
si vous savez qu'il va faire après des
récents jdz pour l'ouverture à droite
est ce que vous pensez qu emmanuel
macron vous qui le connaissaient plus
que nous va'a va aller vers la droite
pour ce pour ce poste là éminemment
important je pense que de la même
manière avec laquelle il va former le
gouvernement vous verrez qu'il ya une
diversité politique sera représentée
voilà c'est la super langue de bois je
peux pas dire plus
dernière question est ce que vous vous
souhaitez ou vous briguer un poste au
sein du futur gouvernement
je suis candidate aux élections
législatives dans la 10ème
circonscription des et si vous gagnez
cette élection ce qu'il y ait d'abord il
faut faire campagne et la gagner et puis
après on verra
mais d'abord il faut gagner cette
élection législative et bat jean
frédéric poisson
merci howard berger d'être venu en
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
candidate sur la 10e circonscription des
yvelines pour la république en marche et
vous serez notamment opposé à jean
claude husson pour le ps guillaume
jlh mythe excusez moi sans étiquette
david jutier pour europe écologie les
verts jean frédéric poisson pour le
parti chrétien démocrate et les
républicains la liste officielle des
candidats sera connu dans une dizaine de
jours merci encore et puis bonne
campagne à vous dans le reste de
l'actualité une bonne nouvelle pour les
usagers de la rd 30 depuis ce vendredi
les automobilistes peuvent circuler sur
une partie du tronçon la voix sous le
giratoire des gâtines et le pont de la
rue jules régnier est désormais ouverte
une première étape qui marque une
avancée significative dans sur ce
chantier d'envergure camille lambert
plus de 30 mille véhicules par jour
circuleront désormais sur cette section
de la rd 30 une avancée attendue dans ce
secteur encombré
l'accès à la rn 12 se veut plus facile
et plus fluide coupe comme ça le flux de
circulation de ceux qui empruntent cette
route départementale 30
je rappelle vient de poissy pour aller
vers elancourt donc franchir ou donner
accès à la nationale 12
vous pouvez maintenant avoir un trafic
séparés entre ce que l'on appelle le
trafic de transit et le trafic qui est
plutôt plaisir war la rd30 élargie à
deux fois deux voies passe sous le
giratoire des gâtines la circulation
s'effectuera sur une file dans chaque
sens jusqu'à l'achèvement des travaux
sur l'ensemble du tracé une mise en
service prévue pour la fin de la nuit
qui doit bien pour noël 2010 est on aura
terminé les gros ouvrages et la
circulation pourra être donnée aux
véhicules à moteur
pourquoi je fais ce distinguo parce que
arrive deux autres ensembles qui sont
des passerelles pour la circulation
douce parce que vous avez une voie verte
une voie verte et 2 passerelle piétons
et cycles qui permettront le
franchissement de la n12 pour rejoindre
elancourt
fin des travaux prévue pour 2018
le collège albert einstein de
magny-les-hameaux bientôt restructurer
une première pour ce bâtiment qui date
des années soixante dix il s'agit d'une
demande de la part des enseignants et
des parents d'élèves qui pointé
plusieurs dysfonctionnements depuis
plusieurs années pierre bédier le
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines
es-tu sur place mercredi pour évoquer
justement ces travaux ils seront menées
par le département un reportage une
nouvelle fois de camille lambert des
salles trop petites
une peinture vieillissante et une
connexion limitée voilà quelques-uns des
problèmes du collège albert einstein
équipes éducatives et parents d'élèves
ont alerté sur la dégradation du
bâtiment lors d'un conseil
d'administration
alexandra rosetti conseillère
départementale a porté la voix auprès du
président des yvelines on voit bien que
en termes de sécurité c'est pas du tout
optimum vu la taille des salles vu le
manque de sorties de secours en terme
d'électricité en termes de réseau de
tout le monde c'est vrai commencé à
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
donc
je pense que c'était
bien qu'on puisse réagir et je suis ravi
que le président est soit venu visiter
de lui même là pour constater
qu'effectivement ce n'était pas exagéré
le président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier a donc visité le bâtiment
d'une quarantaine d'années construit
pour accueillir initialement 600 élèves
il ne peut en recevoir plus de 475 la
rénovation sera totalement prise en
charge par le département
coût total des travaux plus de 6
millions d'euros
on va faire les espaces extérieurs
agrandir le parking des profs refaire
une
[Musique]
une cour
je pense qu'on peut dire de récréation
au collège ensuite nous allons
restructurer un restructurer les salles
de classe
lorsqu'elles sont trop petites refaire a
naturellement tous les couloirs les
revêtements une restructuration qui
s'intègre dans un projet plus large le
département prévoit de rénover 20
établissements d'ici 2021 à magny les
hameaux
les travaux débuteront dès cet été du
sport également dans l'actualité locale
cette semaine et la coupe de france de
l'américaine qui se tenait mercredi
après-midi au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une épreuve de
cyclisme sur piste méconnu que l'on peut
clairement comparé à un relais en tandem
plus de 160 participants répartis dans
cinq catégories étaient présents pour la
compétition les détails avec michael et
demi d'euros ce mercredi 10 mai le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines a accueilli l'une des
compétitions les plus spectaculaires du
cyclisme sur piste la course à
l'américaine alors l'américaine c'est
une épreuve par équipes de deux coureurs
sachant que c'est une épreuve de run et
donc que les power font deux ou trois
toujours ça là ça dépend à l'alluré
où ça roule et passe le relais alors à
leurs collègues et puis tous les
plusieurs dizaines de tours y aller a
dit classement où les gens on doit de
prendre des points pour cette seconde
coupe de france organisée dans la
structure 70 équipes issues de 13
comités régionaux se sont inscrits faire
voir ce qu'on peut
ce qu'on peut donner sur la piste savoir
si on peut surprendre dans une catégorie
ou dans le club c'est important d'être
ici parce que l'on montre un peu pour
déjà les couleurs de l'auvergne
rhône-alpes la maîtrise y rouler sur un
aussi beau vélodrome comme je suis quand
même très content d'y être
sur la piste les cours n'ont pas hésité
à jouer des coudes pour remporter la
victoire au péril de leur sécurité
il n'ya pas toujours la place pour tout
le monde et des fois ya des coureurs qui
veulent passer en dessous alors que par
par code on doit passer au dessus donc
voilà ça s'affrontent notamment chez les
jeunes ne sont pas encore très très
habitué la difficulté d'américaines
c'est qu'il faut voir loin et c'est
compliqué de voir loin quand on roule
vite
les cours qui ont réussi à tenir sur
leurs vélos en réalisant les meilleurs
chronos sont qualifiés pour les futurs
championnats de france 2010 est la
compétition se déroulera cet été à
guyancourt la ville a débuté les
festivités pour les dix ans de la
batterie la salle de concerts prévoit
jusqu'à la fin du mois de mai une série
de concerts justement un effet spécial
de 10 euros la place avec une
programmation éclectique jazz classique
reggae ou de la pop et qui reflète bien
l'histoire de la sarre qui s'est
développée progressivement avec le temps
elle est unique parce que justement elle
est transversal les transversales avec
l'éducation donc l'école de musique elle
est transversal avec les studios avec
des professionnels avec des
professionnels en devenir
voilà cette dimension est quand même dès
le départ importante pour pour nous a
dit en cour d'avoir vraiment un public
varié un point public aussi en direction
de l'éducation mais aussi en direction
bas
du territoire et pour connaître les
dates des concerts pour les dix ans de
la batterie rendez vous sur le site
internet de la salle de conte du concert
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo merci
de nous avoir suivis retrouver tous nos
reportages en replay et sur tv fil 78
points comme ou l'application tv fil 78
bon week-end à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]